il 9
[Musica]
era già scavata già visto no io trovo 2
aiuta a vincere dopo mille anni alla
ricerca del kraken dio mio
l'abbiamo trovato e non avremmo voluto
mai che succedessero lo assicuro non ve
lo so neanche descrivere è gigantesco e
fortissimo cia tutto sto coso il
cracking più spaventoso dei miei capelli
in questo momento vi lascio al video
abbiamo avuto un piccolo scontro anzi
grande scontro con un galeone all'inizio
e poi è uscito il kraken quindi buona
visione
ok ho comprato un sacco di aveva speso
un sacco di soldi per la rai comprato ma
cos'è don matteo
sono un figo considerando che ho speso
un sacco di soldi per diventa così
quando non somigliare almeno a selena
gomez e invece no ma la nave perché è
storta questo è successo riposa dai
ragazzi ai ragazzi fate i seri aiuto vi
raggiungo ciao
siete dei deficienti maratea che fi come
si vede uncino quando riappare come fai
a mettere il proiettile con l'uncino e
manco che andremo controvento
perfettamente blu blu nel mentre che
cade pure l'esorcista ma puoi usare il
secchio veramente brava prova prova
trova a janò non funziona già sicura del
sicuro che non funziona non veda pierce
in faccia non vede niente per ora io non
vorrei essere pignolo ma penso che
stiamo per attaccarli gli va bene ma ci
stavamo preparando alla guerra non vedi
che ha messi così ci hanno sparato
ottiene cosa a surgelati occhio ci
stanno sparando ci stavano aspettando
nella trappola
cambiamo gioco sono i scarsi come la
morte però viene significa ma bastano
evitare da ok
stiamo prendendo un po di battaglia che
vale stop animali in testa quello di
sistemare qualcuno di tv sono io vado io
ciao fratello madonna chiamare sono
tedeschi lo so non vederti in strudel
johnsrud tedeschi de mer di ayachi male
non vi sta attaccando a jesolo è morto
non ci sono non ci sono mi hanno ucciso
chi è che ha preso il tesoro il rumeno
bravo portalo viene ucciso uno solo ma
sono fondati loro della fonda
ma perché stiamo uscendo sulla stessa se
stiamo girando su noi stessi verso che
reca io ma sarà anche l'omesso ragazzi
ci sono modo per vincere la battaglia
ed è questo lo sapevo io ho già colpiti
e colpi di sé due volte anch'io arriva
sulla barca arrivare i vari vari ma
sopra sei anime sopra sono qua sopra ci
sono dovevano foto troppo foto torna
sotto lo sperato
note ucciso come lega stanno scappando
in seguito è che non ci sono ucciso lo
cita gli schianta la manica altro linea
della caf anno perfetto vai quanto mai
c'è un altro tesoro quanti titoli anni
no ma fatto fuori nova tumore
credo o non farcela il pretore il mio
dio lo prendo atto e mi sono buttato
gira un po assist a san onofre non
riesco a salire da voi
gira gira è solo alle zone di così tanti
no no
dove tutto rispetto
vorrei salire sulla nave madonna ma ad
oggi dantesco lega arriva ragazzi c'è un
problema chiaro da loro come negozio è
un mezzo ora il pensiero pensa a farcela
non so persone sopra son sopra vai vai
sul dritto ragazza dei passi non ce la
faremo ma riguarda l'iva per spiegare di
spiegare devo andare non sapete
tentacolo li ha presi a sudditi spacca
in due
no non credo la cosa con la pistola raga
dobbiamo sparare anche a chi e cosa mi
sa fare e lo vedo ma il problema non è
quello è che sono tanti tentacoli sai
come mi aveva pure ma poi rimini già
sono nella chiacchia piena una nave
affondata rega vedo gente che si butta
in mare fortissima porca vacca
sottoposto stanno arrivando non essere
arrivando non salire zona nostra male è
volevi tedeschi in difficoltà ragazzi
diamo una mano
ho chiamato fuori uno ma è pure lo
squalo
ci manca solo quello l'arma infatti ora
lo faccio per te ma cosa che affrontiamo
storia che lega va bene gira la mamma
mia cosa nell'acqua l'acqua e nera
completamente nome di nulla e nulla
vedono nulla è completamente nera
l'acqua percepito gli occhietti del
cracking però davvero
insomma oggi tutti dalle fiamme si sono
ammalati no non avete ora gar ci sono
problemi vado di solito mi chiamano già
molti problemi lega male che stefan
costruito anche le più sensibili puntano
al braccino ragazzi dobbiamo veramente
muoversi regala mi sembra il momento
migliore da lazard mi sembra
incredibilmente il momento migliore per
fare questa cosa io sto sparando anche
la chiara e sto sparando a mio agio è
andata giù tentacolo andato ma è così
fumi libero seccati libero libreria di
ivrea aiuta riesco la nave è troppo
storta ancesco non ci riesco ma salutato
ma scusato dall'altra parte del mondo
credevo che abbiamo davanti è entrato in
modalità aspirapolvere erano scappati ma
che cosa è successo
ho visto nel caso che lo dovevo mai
vedere
sa che vi sto sparando più di così non
lo so non so che fare
sarebbe il cecchino bastato il cerchino
ma mi sa che è un problema grosso questo
cavalcate nagai dark souls
io mi metto dietro ad haga quanto
unisono stipendiali solo b3 tentacoli
abbiamo fatto noi io tra voi due
aiutami c'era non mistura degli amici
amici vi prego aiuti è piuttosto sudicio
quasi come guarda non sento la maglia
che è male terra e dolore forte ragazzi
noi come gardaland solo più viscido come
dita la vascolare no mista mista
inzuppando nell'acqua come se fossi non
so un crostino che schifo sono usciti
farina acqua già fatta e ora che aspetta
privare la barca però sono sotto il
pentacolo mancano solo più stringenti il
33 ragazzo
mancano due anche altri
arrivano due tentacoli abbiamo fatto
anche una sonora andò via da qui beh e
quindi successo è sparito è sparito il
kraken avevamo tutto il club abbia
battuto dai scappato è andato man
battuta ben visto quindi tra via mincio
neanche un grazie a fermarci e stato
bello a diventare un crostino ma mia
vita
che figata dell'isola dove siamo partiti
saranno mai palli di casale gira non
glielo perché dopo un po si defila
credono tutta la pa che ben rubato dalla
lisei spuntato dal nulla come possibile
con la fisarmonica pure mi è comparso
dal nulla con la fisarmonica bene vabbè
ecco qua in quanto vera traguardo mi
sono rotto una gamba e fa bene
com'è possibile chi beve ma basta avere
bello e stu viaggio ma l'austriaco 6
serie smettere in quanto video perdonare
saranno creati bravo a xfactor coppia
che finisce al largo e niente in italia
super party cia riafferma quindi abbiamo
battuto il kraken nel senso che il
kraken non è che lo batti se butti giù
tutti i tentacoli rimane con due o tre
tentacoli su e poi scappa c'è nel senso
non è che esce fuori e muore scappa
proprio quando si ritirano gli ultimi
due tre tentacoli appare la notifica è
battuto il cracking che voi non vedete
nel video ce l'abbiamo fatta ed è stato
veramente difficile ma ce l'abbiamo
fatta
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio i miei tour mieri pirati
compagni di avventure e amici di polipo
e proprio video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
conseguire giorno mi piace richiedenti
non ci diamo ai ragazzi
[Musica]